the following program is rated G A G it
contains giggling abominable language
and grotesque sexual imagery it may
literally cause you to gag we highly
recommend you don't watch it just walk
away and just go read a book or
something or spend time with your kids
do anything but watch this gag reel
but for real
you better be working on that Dean you
better be working on that [__]
blooper wheel Dean
[Music]
Parks and Rec Let's Roll
oh
I have one suit my brown Sears three
piece
what's your name again Elise yarkton
Elaine snarkins
at least snarkins
again
sorry that's stupid okay come over to my
house at three so you can help me
prepare make sure that Mark is coming I
have so much work to do you're my very
best friend
yeah
I'm sorry
so it's just getting worse
[Music]
she ran into the door jamb
are you okay
wait okay
[Music]
hello
hey Mom you're on camera right now say
hi Mom
hello
next caller I uh you work with animals
right uh yes I do I work a lot with
animals I love it well what is it about
cats that make them think they are so
much goddamn better than we are
I'll take my answer I'll see you
[Laughter]
don't play if you can't deal with the
consequences this [__] is on little man
[Laughter]
oh sorry guys I lost this little Pom-Pom
that was on my golf glove should be on
the floor somewhere can you help me look
for it real quick
laughs
[Applause]
[Laughter]
should we do it again just like that
three more times
[Laughter]
and then
and then he passed away
[Laughter]
will you just help me
help me open thank you
what I was saying is that awesome girls
like you who are you know not
classically hot they can go and they can
be rewarded for
an idiot
Leslie I have been happily married for
28 years I you've met my wife Gail many
times so
um
oh finally Ann and Mark will um
be well mistake is so bad
I'm so sorry
[Music]
I've never done a horse tape yeah let's
start again
so um
so I uh
[Music]
Leslie doesn't like to hear her mommy
talk about sex
did you hear that why don't you tell us
about your eska pigs you little minks
[__] is wrong with you
I like your padfolio so I'd like to talk
about
[Laughter]
every sorry
I saw your head sorry
everything I'm sorry
government brand tooth powder
and it doesn't get your teeth clean and
it tastes like
[Laughter]
this and it doesn't get your teeth clean
and it tastes like [__]
would you gentlemen like a tour not at
all there is quite literally nothing in
the world that I would rather do
than take a tour of the Parks and Rec
Department
hey guess what what's that I'm awesome
okay lucky to have me here because I'm
farting on this money
I'm awesome okay and you're lucky to
have me here because I'm farting on some
money and I'm a prize
okay and you're lucky to have me here
because I'm far and I'm smiling [__]
[__]
I'm so sorry I'm kicking your ass in
Pizza fight
really I really wish I would do it
try it with a different suit
Jay
what I thought you'd like this one
laughs
Jay I thought you'd like this one I do T
[Laughter]
Justin and I have a similar fashion
sense dangerous in your face but
tasteful
you like this new button down
purple
sweater vest combo
solid Brook Brothers bought it off the
doll
a vanilla chai latte for my young Nubian
person
step one
we buy into this club step two we roll
over to the club either in your
Mercedes-Benz which is gorgeous or my
pre-owned Acura Legend which is our
step three a dagger you on the Dance
Floor Just Bounce Bounce Bounce Bounce
bounce bounce bounce but bounce now
everybody's watching us
oh
step three
I dagger you on that dance floor
and dress you with my eyes until at last
it's just me and you naked on the Dance
Floor
you throw up you're gonna smile
Dean I'm gonna give you 50 takes of this
one line
take one
and I'll do my make sure read
it entirely understand youth culture
I'm a much happier person now though is
the thing and I just want
I just screwed up the whole take that's
what I did did you yeah shall we go back
yeah I want
to see stock
there
weird after
but then it was okay
dog died later
eight
sorry
bananama that's close
[Laughter]
where are we going
into your mother's butt
oh I think we can make a right turn on
wait a minute my mother's
so uh maybe we should just write um
things down
go from there
will you do it because I don't know how
to write
print or
[Laughter]
bye Carl
I don't mean this in any bad way
but have you ever made out with another
woman
why
because for my analysis
I think you'd love it